all politics is tribal
at this point and a lot of folks and i
had this experience directly will just
completely shut down if you have a d
next to your name or an r next to your
name right so if you have something
neutral next to your name they were like
i don't know what to make of this
exactly right you know i mean the the
the the label democrat is so loaded
right now for so many people uh but you
know you could have the same person
saying the exact same things with
something else next to them it's called
an independent or a forwardist or
whatever and people would have a
completely different reaction right and
you know you you kind of make some
gestures just to some cultural identity
symbols that are important and suddenly
oh this is a different person
[Music]
i am thrilled to have with me on the
podcast senior fellow at new america
which is this
extraordinary think tank
the author of breaking the two-party
doom loop so you know that i like him
political science phd
lee drutman welcome lee hey it's great
to be with you andrew really excited for
this conversation
well lee you are ahead of me on this and
you've literally written books about
this uh but you also do have a phd in
political science which is something
that a lot of people studied as
undergrads myself included at brown um
and certainly i stopped there i think
most people stop there so we'd love to
hear a little bit about
how you came to this field were you
always deeply interested in politics as
a young person you know i was actually
an english major at brown uh so i i was
actually not super into politics but i
as i
kind of entered my 20s and i started out
as a newspaper reporter and just got
more and more
interested in politics and
yeah decided it would be uh fun to get a
phd in political science because then
i'd have an excuse to just read a lot
and hang out and think and
and then it just totally totally grabbed
me and fascinated me so you got your phd
from berkeley in the early 2000s uh and
then did you head straight to dc is that
right yeah so i did three years of
course work in berkeley and then i went
to to dc to do research for my phd
dissertation which was about corporate
lobbying in dc and i figured the best
way to do research was to talk to a
bunch of corporate lobbyists and ask
them about what they did and hang out
with them and and i learned a lot
yeah you wrote a book about lobbying is
that right that is right that was that
was it's called the business of america
is lobbying
wow so
uh can you summarize for us what's going
on on that front i'm just going to give
you the general understanding
uh there's a lot of lobbying
it's done by really big companies
it works great in the sense that they
they can
kneecap any uh move that is going to
hurt them
uh and that's pretty much it is that a
reasonable summary
yeah
that is a pretty good summary yeah one
of the things that i i
was particularly interested in writing
this book was how
corporate lobbying had sort of just come
to overtake washington dc and whether
there was anything
we all should be doing about it so in
the how corporate lobbying just you know
overtook washington dc the the thing
that i realized was that you know once
companies started lobbying they tended
to lobby more and more because they
hired lobbyists who then said oh here
are all these things that you should be
lobbying for and here are all these
things that the government might do to
hurt your business so it just kind of
became this
self-perpetuating business that just
kind of ate policy making in washington
and i said well how do lobbyists have
all this power so some of it is the
conventional story of of campaign
contributions but a lot of it is just
that lobbyists have this incredible
monopoly on
policy expertise and what you find when
you go inside of a lot of congressional
offices and even some committee offices
is or most committee offices is you find
not that many staff and the staff who
are there are kind of overworked
underpaid and and a bit on the
inexperienced side because as soon as
they
achieve a certain amount of experience
they they burn out and they want to get
some real money by being a corporate
lobbyist
yeah i i've experienced some
parts of this uh
through friends who are on capitol hill
but i do want to dig into this because
it's fascinating and i want to share
with you an onion article that helped
motivate my entire career in politics
and the onion articles about 16 years
ago and it goes like this
it says the american people
hire
high-powered lobbyists to represent
their interests in washington and then
there's a guy in a suit standing there
and saying with me
representing the american people like
well actually you know like see things
uh happen and i thought this was
hysterically funny but i also thought
wow this is kind of accurate
[Laughter]
uh and
um so a couple of things to for context
the lobbying industry has dramatically
mushroomed in size over the last number
of years that that that's right right
that is correct though it's kind of
flatlined over the last decade and a
half or or so only grown slightly but
there was a really big growth in the 90s
and the early 2000s so give us order of
magnitude from what to what from like
let's say the early 90s so yeah it went
from about uh you know one
one and a half
maybe about a one billion
[Music]
dollar
industry to about a three or four
billion dollar industry and that's just
in reported lobbying and by the way i do
remember that onion cartoon or onion
onion article and i loved it
you loved it too look at that the onion
ahead of the curb so it quadruple so
lobbying quadrupled in size as an
industry roughly
and that's disclosed amounts from the
early 90s to let's call it 2010. yeah
uh so that's
a lot uh and i have friends who worked
on capitol hill who became lobbyists and
to your point they get paid more a lot
more as lobbyists
and so there's this concern a lot of
americans have about the revolving door
from
government to industry as a lobbyist i
think at least one
study i saw said that a majority of
former legislators
became either lobbyists or associated
with lobbyists in particular ways
and their staffers showed a very similar
migration
um that's also accurate yeah there's a
pretty high uh what they call in
washington the revolving door from uh
government to industry you know it's a
pretty nice place to land and a lot of
these folks don't even actually do all
that much work other than make a few
phone calls here and there especially
the former members
wow that does sound like a pretty good
gig um the like i know someone who
worked on capitol hill was relatively
senior not a member himself um but he
got paid you know like two to three
times his previous salary that's about
right
uh and so you have this entire industry
of people i also i'm going to share some
more lobbying stories i went to a
lobbying breakfast as a guest a number
of years ago where there was a senator
and then he was just sitting down for
breakfast and i think that his campaign
was getting i don't know ten thousand
twelve thousand dollars to have this
breakfast and so he'd be
eating his breakfast he was bored out of
his mind and then there's some people
around him who were just talking to him
about i think in this case it was like
import policies or something something
that was really not very interesting
and then i was there and i felt like
keeping my mouth shut because i was
there for free like i didn't pay
anything it was just a friend who was at
the lobbying firm brought me
and the actual dynamic was very
different where as soon as i was
introduced and it was clear i was not a
lobbyist the senator became very
interested in me
because it was like oh someone i can
talk to that doesn't have this stupid
agenda that i don't care about that i'm
just kind of
suffering through to get this twelve
thousand dollars into my my account
um but it it did strike me how deeply
insinuated the system was where a
legislator would just sort of shrug and
accept that you know like that their
breakfast was going to be
uh unpleasant um just to you know just
get some more money flowing into their
coffers yeah that's that's that's the
name of the game and they all complain
about it especially once they retire
spend oh they say oh i spent all this
money
sorry i spent all this time raising
money and it was so unpleasant but
that's just what i got to do to get
elected and i guess
it's pretty nice to be a senator it
feels feels important feel like you're
doing big things and
you've gotta
spend your time
dialing for the for the dollars or or
eating scrambled eggs for the dollars or
whatever whatever it is but it's all for
the dollars well yeah the eggs were not
bad i had some eggs
they were good
good
so you wrote this book about lobbying
when
that book came out in 2015 the business
of america is lobbying the business of
america's lobbying circa 2015 year
before trump takes office so during this
time as uh a new political
uh science phd you wound up hooking up
with new america which is a think tank
around the same time is that right yeah
yeah that's right
a new america for people who aren't
familiar with it is a think tank that
people regard as
uh very independent somewhat left
leaning
um the head of it is a woman named anne
marie slaughter who received a ton of
notice for a number of things i mean
she's a powerhouse yeah she has a ton of
incredible work um she wrote one article
and she's done a lot of things other
than this but this is i think one of the
most well-known things that people will
associate with there was an article a
number of years ago that said something
like women can't have it all and she
talked about her own incredible
career in public service but talked
about all of the various sacrifices that
were attendant with it that's right
[Music]
we all want to be lifelong learners
isn't that a great phrase lifelong
learner the problem is how the heck do
you learn new things how do you do it
from the comfort of your own home in a
way that's affordable and accessible the
way to do it my friends is skillshare
and a friend of mine founded this
company it really does fill a massive
need do you want to get better
photography there's a class for that you
want to get better at design a class for
that you just want to be more productive
in general yes there is a class for that
and skillshare and it is affordable and
as all get out you can have a
subscription for less than ten dollars a
month
you know
how much people charge for this stuff in
other contexts and sometimes it's worth
it but sometimes you just wanna have
access to resources that will point you
in the right direction and then put you
on your merry way to developing new
skills that is skillshare you can
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com yang and get a one month
free trial of premium membership that's
one month of a premium membership at
skillshare.com yang you know you can
figure out if this is working for you in
a month i mean that's a month it's 30
days 31 maybe it's probably 30.
skillshare.com yang check it out
[Music]
uh so you joined new america also around
the time this book came out yeah a
little bit before but yeah that's good
fun
and since then you become one of the
leading voices on
issues with a duopoly shall we say like
how did your attention end up uh being
drawn to this topic
well
so
after i wrote the this book on corporate
lobbying one of the things that i sort
of set myself
to do was to try to see if i could
convince congress to spend more money on
its own staff and expertise because i
realized that one way to fight back
against the influence of lobbyists would
be to give congress some of its own
independent power to actually evaluate
policy and develop policy without having
to rely on these armies and i do mean
armies of of corporate lobbyists who
basically shape the
policy-making
environment and so i went around duly
talking to congressional offices and
people in and around congress everybody
said yeah of course we should do this
and then
i tried to convince people
in the alleged branch appropriations
world which is a very small world in
which congress sets its own budget i
said look you spend so little on
yourselves lobbies spend so much more
why don't you spend more on staff and
they say oh yeah well we probably should
but the politics of it are kind of kind
of not so great
and you know i i sort of realized at
some point that this system
is not going to change because you have
a structure of congress that's
incredibly top-down with party leaders
basically controlling everything and
what that means is that the the
independent offices of members of
congress and the committees are starved
of resources so that the leadership can
control everything and moreover there's
very little for rank and file members in
congress to actually do policy-wise
because all they're doing is running
to
win the next election and it's
always the next election even when you
just had the last election and moreover
because the everything is so gridlocked
and divided and polarized the only thing
you do is you beat up on the other side
and as this is happening or sort of
seeing the rise of trump and this is a
kind of a big
puzzle for a lot of folks in 2016. where
did this guy come from and you know so
at the same time i'm sort of struggling
with trying to figure out how do you get
congress to invest more in its own
capacity i i'm kind of
trying to understand how we got to this
moment in which donald trump is not only
able to win the republican party
nomination but become president so i
start doing kind of my own
understanding of the history of how we
got to this moment which i talk a lot
about in breaking the two-party doom
loop and you know look at the kind of
escalating partisan polarization and how
it's really you know a
polarization that is around
identity and the story of america and
that's just really a very dangerous and
unresolvable polarization and how that
feeds in and exacerbates the the
two-party system and then i said well
okay what does the rest of the world do
which is something that i don't think a
lot of americans think about i said oh
actually
the us is really the only
two-party system among advanced
democracies and oh
no continue continue and oh hey a bunch
of countries
use this system called proportional
representation in which parties
are allowed to compete in these
multi-member proportional districts so
they get a share of seats in the
legislature that's commensurate with
their popularity and that allows for
multiple parties to flourish and hey
that actually seems to work pretty well
because then parties bargain together
and coalitions are fluid and those
countries seem to be a lot better at
solving problems and hey maybe we should
try that and hey maybe i should write a
book about it
wow so first let's return for a moment
to you're trying to develop congress's
policymaking capacity first i am for
increasing
uh staff for salaries and budgets uh i'm
for increasing member salaries as well
though i know the optics of that
politically
are considered poor
but i said look you know it would be a
very small price to pay for a more
functional legislature if people weren't
so beholden to industry and this
lobbying dynamic is certainly part of it
so what you're suggesting is that for
individual members
their policy making resources are kind
of
secondary because they don't really get
that much central uh
sway as to what the policy is going to
be and it's really in the leadership
does the leadership have robust
resources that they draw on when they're
trying to figure out what policies that
that they'd want to push they have
decently robust resources i would say i
mean
even within the leadership i mean a lot
of the resources are are oriented
towards communications and marketing
of policies and i mean so much of
politics now is not about governing it's
about the perpetual campaign and because
we have these two parties that are
fighting over this very narrow bit of
terrain of some some sort of you know
ill-defined center of maybe swing voters
or apparently seven percent of voters
but continue oh is that is that what
your your support is no no no no it's uh
that the proportion of americans who
will cross party lines on the regular uh
has diminished from 22 to seven percent
yeah that's why i threw that number out
because i because i had seen a poll
where where you were at seven percent in
a trump
uh
biden match up recently yeah i'm i think
i'm around that level thank you yang
gang love you
so i'm with you on the need to increase
congressional resources though you're
hitting a very powerful point which is
look the incentives now politically are
not around policy yeah
they're around politics and optics and
yes you know trying to win the next race
um so think tanks play another role
which is that you all can also provide
policy input
that theoretically at least is
independent of lobbying interests uh
that that that's the role you all play
right yeah that's that's the role we're
supposed to play
yeah and and so
um certainly i mean i i i'll say that
i'm glad that think tanks uh exist
because at least they're like a
different
look different set of uh perspectives
and you know even though obviously
you know different organizations have
different um
like alignments
i think that you know like i've seen a
lot of good stuff flow from think tanks
personally yeah i think we do an okay
job at new america
so
so circa 2015 2016 you start thinking
wow
it turns out that policy is not the main
driver or the not the main priority for
you all it's around this other stuff
and then you realize that our political
incentives are very misshapen relative
to
other countries out there and you
mentioned that there's a point at which
we became polarized
can you trace back and you wrote a book
um that digs into the history but when
the heck did polarization
start to get worse uh because right now
people are kind of used to it but it was
not always this way that's right so in
fact you know i i kind of traced the
history of how we got to here and i
started in 1950 when the american
political science association puts out
this report
arguing for a responsible two-party
system and the critique of the us system
is that the parties are
indistinguishable from each other that
they're basically democrats and
republicans are basically the same
they're both in the you know these broad
overlapping coalitions of state and
local parties that don't really stand
for anything or they stand for the same
thing and voters have no meaningful
choice so what we need to become a
real democracy is for voters to have
choice and for there to be two parties
that stand for two different things and
of course you know
nobody really listens to the political
scientists but that that prophecy did
kind of come true uh so starting the
1960s the you know particularly around
the
issue of civil rights the party started
to realign the democratic party since
the new deal had been a coalition of
northern liberals and southern
conservatives and you know once the
democratic party comes to kind of own
the civil rights issue there go this
other con conservative democrats who
eventually migrate into the republican
party and
start in the 70s 80s
you see
culture war issues start to take center
stage more and more in american politics
and politics begin to nationalize more
and more and what happens is that the
southern conservatives go from being
democrats to republicans and a lot of
the northeastern
liberal republicans go to becoming
democrats so what used to be a kind of
four-party system a multi-party system
with liberal republicans and
conservative democrats alongside
conservative republicans and
liberal democrats basically collapses
flattens into a two-party system uh and
you know real really this really
kind of
speeds up in the 90s there you know we
sort of think about the the gingrich
takeover of of congress as kind of a
watershed moment but what gingrich was
really doing in that election was he was
nationalizing elections uh kind of
taking away politics from the old every
all politics is local to focusing on the
national platform of the republican
party
and
really
engaging in a much more aggressive
attack on on the clinton administration
and democrats in general and
that
really starts a a real
kind of kind of sea change in the
way in which elections are conducted and
the fact that the house had been in
democratic control for basically for 40
years up until that point there was kind
of a sense probably you know
from in the 80s and even to the early
90s that you know democrats basically
had the house and republicans were going
to win the presidency most of the time
and americans wanted divided government
so the party should work together well
clinton wins in 92 so now democrats can
win the white house republicans take
over congress in 94 so now republicans
can win the house and every election is
a toss-up election and
so the
the the competitiveness goes up of
national elections and the parties start
to
to pull apart the republican party
becomes more and more centered around
southern conservatives uh much more much
more conservative the sort of liberal
northeastern wing that sort of
represents the kind of traditionalist
you know kind of kind of
cautious
uh you know small c conservativism is is
gone and the democratic party which had
been split between kind of the the urban
you know northern liberals and the
southern western rural conservatives
becomes much more dominant dominated by
the northern and urban urban liberals
and so the the images of the party in
the public mind become much sharper
parties stand for much
clearer differences and
swing voters disappear cross-pressured
voters are forced into one side or the
other and everything becomes about
winning the next election in which case
the party that is the opposition party
wants to make the governing party the
party in the white house look bad so
there's no cooperation and all this kind
of ratchets
on itself keeps getting worse and worse
more demonization more sorting and so we
have this two-party system now in which
there's really no overlap and the
radical thing really is a genuine
two-party system in this country that
that is the truly radical change
so we're
let's say 27 years in because newt
gingrich won in 94 right now so we're 27
years into this new polarization you
describe and your research
shows that we are unique in this regard
as well in terms of the depth of the
polarization right yeah well i i mean
not not entirely unique
this level of polarization
is uh what you find in hungary and
turkey so you know
we have some company
in
although apparently you know hungary is
the new there's the darling of the new
tucker carls of the tucker carlson right
now
so
again you know not necessarily
where you want to be in the u.s so i
found your international research should
be fascinating where you you point out
that america right now is not normal in
terms of
uh various other democracies around the
world
there were some other findings i thought
were were fascinating too from your work
around the fact that because there are
two parties um the actual affection for
one's
identified party is not as high as it is
in other environments
yeah so the the cross-national stuff is
really fascinating there's been a
growing uh amount of research on this in
political science so you know generally
political scientists try
measure
kind of how people feel towards their
own party and how people feel towards
the out party so one of the things in
it's not surprising when you have more
parties people are more likely to feel
good about the party that they're voting
for because when you have five or six
parties you're more likely to find a
party that
speaks to you or speaks for you yeah
exactly
and whereas when there's only two
parties a lot of people feel like
they're voting for the lesser of two
evils or i don't really like either of
the parties but you know i gotta vote
for one because that's you know really
really all i have
so
that so that's part of it and people
people like their parties better when
there's more to choose from but people
also are okay with other parties and
multi-party systems a little more now
there's two reasons for this one is that
in the u.s system
because people don't really love their
parties that much what both parties try
to do is to convince people that the
other party is truly dangerous truly
extreme truly evil the only way to to
unify our party is to have a common
enemy so whatever divisions we have you
know we we can work past them if the
other side is you know basically evil
also
because of the way that the
geographic partisan polarization has
worked in the u.s most people are
surrounded by people of the same party
so it's a lot easier
to demonize the other party when you you
don't really know anybody who votes for
them and people who vote for them are
people who have very different values
and live in very different places so
those two things contribute
and you know in a multi-party system
[Music]
there's no lesser of two evils argument
because if there's five you can yell and
say the other party is too extreme but
then there's a bunch of other options so
that that kind of negative campaigning
is not quite nearly
as profitable uh
and also be because there are multiple
parties there's going to be a few
parties of the left in more rural areas
and a few parties are the right and more
urban areas uh and so people are more
likely to know people who vote for
different ads it's harder to dehumanize
the other side if you actually know
people who are in that party and then
you'll be like oh wait a minute that
person's in my car pool they're not so
bad yes so i read something you wrote
that you suggested the optimal number of
parties would be between four and six
inclusive is that right
that yeah i would say between four and
six now you know i mean that's
that that's my assessment it's based on
you know a sense that
you know
more than more than six it probably
becomes a little harder to differentiate
between the parties for voters i mean
you know you want to give people some
choice but not an overwhelming choice
you know when you if you go to the
grocery store and there's you know 30
different kinds of
cheerios you know yeah streamline it for
me please yeah yeah give me some choice
but like you know i'd like to have more
than two choices of cereal yes i i think
four or five or six sounds like uh a
great target for a
number of parties
[Music]
hello everyone here on forward the
podcast you know what a slogan of mine
is efficiently and unofficially in life
set it and forget it like you just want
to put something in motion and then have
it simplify your life so you don't have
to deal with it
quip is like that for all of your oral
hygiene stuff they send you an electric
toothbrush they send you new heads they
send you toothpaste they send you floss
it's all high tech sleek it's from the
future i love this service i love this
product it makes your mouth better
maintained and you never have to think
about it at all just when something is
about to run out they send you a new one
it's like they're in your bathroom but
they're not in your bathroom i can't
tell you how much this service ends up
upgrading your life you never have to be
like oh can someone get me some more
stuff it just happens like magic if this
sounds good to you
go to get quip dot com slash yang right
now you will get your first refill free
that's your first refill for free at get
quip dot com slash yang spelled g-e-t
q-u-i-p
dot com slash yang quip the good habits
company is their slogan and i gotta say
that's a pretty good slogan but it's
true set it and forget it people get
quipped
so you started digging into this stuff
in 2016 2017 did you coin the term doom
loop is that one of your claims to fame
i i popularized it all right i i i was
it was it preceded me um but but i
i might
you know my publisher i i was a little
resistant to
to having that as the the title of my
book uh but my publisher was like you
got it you got to do it people are going
to remember that
people do remember doom loop the
two-party doom loop breaking the
two-party doom loop by lee drutman so
you settled on
this reality which by the way i i've now
joined you in which is like oh my gosh
like that this two-party system is not
going to work it's actually not designed
to work
necessarily and so we should stop
expecting it to work um so you dug into
it and started publishing pieces in 538
and in other places in law reviews
around this set of ideas
and what is that
timeline been like for you your book
came out in 2019 you were publishing
pieces before then
after then obviously your work gets more
and more relevant germaine as the
election comes and polarization gets
worse and worse can you describe the
reaction you've gotten
and
the the journey of being one of the in
my opinion preeminent voices of this
entire school of thought
well that's very kind of you andrew i'm
glad to have you as as part of this
growing movement uh i'm glad to be here
man i mean you're one of the
intellectual uh progenitors of it so
yeah well thank you
although i can't claim to have invented
multi-party democracy um but yeah you
know i published the
the book came out in uh in january of 20
20 20 or i guess official pub data is
like
2019 or something um
so you know and i
and i you know did the did the usual
book tour podcast uh circuit and yeah i
mean the the general reaction was yeah
that sounds like something we should do
it seems like we should have more than
two parties uh seems like there's a lot
of pathology with our party system but
you know
like come on man you know that's never
gonna happen that's just a pipe dream uh
so like yeah i mean i remember i
remember talking to
one
one prominent washington dc journalist
at a at a party and i told her i'd
written this book she said yeah you know
i love your writing but like you know
i'm not i'm not interested in books
about things that'll never happen so you
know that was
kind of the the reality that i that i
started out with uh and i you know i i
think
after january 6 something really changed
in that suddenly people were a lot more
interested in structural reform and
suddenly people realized oh wait we
thought that after trump left that that
things were going to go back to normal
oh
things are not at all normal but we i
think we need to do something
much more radical than than we thought
and so i mean i've seen the conversation
just expand tremendously over the course
of this year as as the reality has set
in that you know there's no there's no
back to normal
it only gets worse from here if we don't
do anything
amen i am with you there a couple of
thoughts i've had that i may not have
shared with everyone um
they might be in my uh twitter drafts
but i'm going to show them now
one was it was almost easier when you
could blame everything on one person
where i think there were a lot of people
who thought well if you defeat trump
then things will quote unquote
snap back to normal
and then you realize that this
unfortunately is the new normal that
we're struggling with which is a time of
collapsing trust
a time of people questioning whether
democracy is going to make it through
the next number of years
and one of the lessons that i've drawn
from the last number of months that i
think a lot of people share is that at
this point everything is on the table in
terms of realistic scenarios for the
united states of america and by that i
generally mean bad stuff yeah things
could go in a lot of directions the the
the range if possible is
wild to contemplate it's very very broad
because we've already seen
scenes in american life that would have
been considered science fiction or
dystopian or or
unrealistically nightmarish just a
number of months prior so everything
should be on the table um and that
should include some positive things
along the lines of the structural
reforms that you advocate yeah so
one thing i love about your writing too
is that you are unafraid to put real
solutions out there and a lot of folks
in america today they can
describe a problem and then they
actually veer away when it's time to
solve it
that's like a a pet peeve of mine shall
we say
um so your book did not do that your
book recommends a combination of ranked
choice voting and proportional
representation
uh and i'm a fan of both of these things
can you talk about what you see as our
most plausible path towards real reform
yeah so you know i i
and uh
and and i agree there's a lot of folks
who are you know diagnosing problems and
then say i i don't know how to solve it
it's what academics often call the
chapter 10 problem which is you know you
have to write the solutions in chapter
10. so you know i i've never heard that
term but now i will totally use it
everywhere it's like hey guys write the
[ __ ] chapter 10 because
after nine chapters of scaring the [ __ ]
out of someone with problems or
describing the dysfunction which
i think we've all done this we've read
these books where it's like okay okay
you've got me you've got me i'm down i'm
down and then you wait for the fix and
then you're like what the heck happened
to the fix whereas in your case you
actually had a chapter 10. yeah so i
mean my book was really oriented around
building a case for why we ought to have
more partisan why we ought to change how
how we vote so the first thing to
understand is that the fact that we have
only two parties is not a function of
americans wanting just two problems
because god knows americans want more
parties and yeah we we've been you know
pollsters have been been asking this
question for decades and do you do do
you think the two parties are doing an
adequate job or do you want more parties
and you know for for decades 60 65
percent of americans have been saying
yeah we want more than two parties
but problem is when you have
single member districts with plurality
voting
third parties are treated as spoilers
wasted votes so
once you
try to start a third party everybody
yells and screams you're going to steal
votes
you mean that happens i'm joking
obviously because that was the main
thing i got over this last month
continue continue so
now
the us is is really very unique in in
almost everywhere democracy is is really
weird when you look at this is uniquely
dysfunctional continue
indeed
but most advanced democracies don't use
single member districts they use
multi-member districts with proportional
allocation of votes or they use some
kind of hybrid system in which their
compensatory party list votes so that
you instead of having to get to 51
percent you can get 25
or 20 of support in a district and then
you get representation in the
legislature so we just uh i don't know
how many folks who are following the
recent german elections but the winning
party which is the center left party got
got i think about 26 percent of the vote
and so they get 26 of the seats and
germany has six parties including one
far-right party and the the parties get
seats in the legislature in
you know
rough proportion to how many votes they
get now that allows more parties to form
because the the u.s has two-party system
because in order order to win a seat in
any district you've got to get
plurality usually you know 50 50 51 at
least of
votes in that district and that means
that anything that's not one of the two
major parties is a is a spoiler uh and
so if you have larger districts
you can have more parties that's the
basic rule of things the larger the
district size the more parties you can
have now in the extreme version you have
israel which is one
the entire country is one electoral
district they people vote for parties
instead of candidates and israel
probably has too many parties
i i think it has 17 17 numbers yes in
the last election uh on the other hand
the netherlands has the same almost the
same exact voting system they have 13
parties in their legislature including
an animal rights party and a party for
for seniors and wow i mean the dutch
system seems to work pretty well uh so
they're you know across europe there are
different
uh countries that use different formulas
but all of them fall broadly into the
category of proportional representation
so you know the key to to getting there
is to end the single member district
which we use for for the house and
there's no reason why we have to have
the single member district we've had
multi-member districts in in our earlier
history it's not not anywhere in the
constitution the framers never never
debated although thomas jefferson
actually came up with an early early
version of proportional representation
that he was one of the one of the uh the
originators but he never quite worked it
out enough to to be used but of course
the framers thought we weren't going to
have political parties uh which i think
was i think that yes yeah which was you
know i mean i think i think we realize
that
you can't really have modern mass
democracy without political parties
political parties are essential which is
you know you saw more than two yeah well
you just want more than two yes
you want to avoid the binary binary
thinking is is very dangerous it puts us
into us versus them and you know the
framers
although they you know they certainly
were opposed to parties one of the
things that if you read them closely
what they feared was just two parties
yeah john adams was like two parties
would be a great evil because you divide
the country in half i mean with multiple
parties you can i mean this is
fundamentally you know the the
madisonian theory of government is you
want to you know gifting factions you
have to team up together exactly
exactly and the teams will change over
time you don't want a system where some
folks feel like they're permanent losers
because then they're going to view the
system as illegitimate and you don't
want a system where some folks feel like
they're permanent winners because then
they're going to use that power to
oppress everyone else
[Music]
here on the forward podcast we are all
about the fact that your data should be
yours the fact is that people can snoop
on every move you make online and some
of us are doing stuff that frankly you
do not want anyone else to know about
[Laughter]
so what to do
the thing to do is to get your own
virtual private network and the one we
recommend here at board is expressvpn
it's the top rated vpn on cnet companies
use it all of the big firms that are
smart about their data use it and you
should use it too a vpn's like beaming
into a private computer someplace else
and then everything you do is anonymous
no one knows what the heck is up you can
even get some choice european-based
content uh you know what i mean like
netflix has different stuff you know
what i mean anyway secure your online
data today by visiting expressvpn.com
yang that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash yang and you can get an
extra three months for free at
expressvpn.com
your data should be all yours
let everyone else not know what the heck
you're doing be safe out there
expressvpn.com
[Music]
yeah so there is a bill uh that was put
forward that tries to move us towards
proportional representation it's a fair
representation is that correct yeah fair
presentation act sponsored by
congressman don beyer
and others and one of the the things
that has been raised is that our
population has increased so dramatically
since all of this stuff got drawn up
that it could be that the number of
representatives we have
is too small
oh oh it definitely is too small i mean
we've been fixed at 435 house members
since uh 1911 although from the uh you
know the vintage congress of of 1789
started at 65 members of the every
census the house increased its size
and then we just stopped around 1911 for
somewhat arbitrary reasons the the us
compared to i mean the german bundestag
has about 700 members the french
parliament has about 700 members british
parliament has somewhere in the 600s so
the
and the u.s has a much larger population
so yeah we should have a
significantly larger passive
representatives too
yes and that would certainly lend itself
towards uh the the multi-member
districts that you're
arguing for
um so one of the struggles i have is
that it seems like a very very dramatic
uh switch though i agree with the goal i
agree with the paradigm change obviously
i mean i'm devoting
uh my waking life to trying to make uh
much of this happen bless you oh thank
you lee bless you too
uh so one of the arguments i'm making is
around open primaries and ranked choice
voting as an incentive improvement
regardless even if let's say
hypothetically a lot of the same people
won
yeah that at least your incentives would
be better and you argue for ranked
choice voting as well as a way to
uh enable a lot of these changes um in
any context is that right yeah yeah yeah
i'm a supporter uh so
uh so i take it you're favorable
towards uh the forward parties open
primaries and ranked choice voting
initiatives even if you think that
that's a step towards this truly
more uh representative system that
doesn't go as far as the fair
representation act yeah i mean you know
i'm i'm not
i'm not a huge fan of open primaries to
be honest i i just get rid of primaries
all together interesting i i don't think
there's any reason that we need
primaries and the thing i worry a little
bit about open primaries as i tend to be
a little
a little concerned about things that are
basically basically cut parties out of
out of the activity yeah i think parties
are incredibly important and by focusing
on on things like nonpartisan open
primaries who actually undermine the
ability of parties to to choose their
candidates and control their candidates
and control their
message which i think is is really
important for being able to connect with
voters and so there's kind of a standard
you know we know what we know what a
forward party candidate is we know what
a forward party candidate stands for an
open primary you're taking that ability
away from the party uh and you know i
think the the challenge i mean you know
trump you know was k
the by opening up primaries too much you
allow you know any any demagogue to come
in and claim i'm a republican i'm a
democrat uh i think i think that was a
tremendous mistake that we made in the
history of this country in the
progressive era there were kind of two
paths one one was an incipient movement
for proportional representation and the
other was a movement for direct
primaries and i think
and both of them were challenging the
sort of corruption of the two-party
system at the time uh you know but i i
think that that was the mistake in the
progressive era was trying to assume
that we could focus and make everything
non-partisan and open rather than just
expanding the number of parties and
giving people more meaningful choice
so i am a fan of the fair representation
act um it seems like it has been
something of a non-starter in terms of
yeah it has been people i mean there
just hasn't been a lot of push around it
and you know part of this is is a matter
of so of of people coming to understand
uh you know what what would that mean i
mean the you know the the democracy
reform space in congress has been you
know totally taken up with with what are
very urgent and very real challenges
around voting rights and i certainly am
a tremendous supporter of the freedom to
vote act uh which is now up for debate
in congress yeah it's stalled in the
senate because that right now
uh you need to bypass the filibuster
which they don't have the votes for
unless a critical number of senators
uh decides that the filibuster shouldn't
stand in the way of the freedom to vote
act um which i'm on that page by the way
that
uh
the filibuster standing in the way of
protecting voting
is not
the right way to go in my opinion uh
given given what we're facing yeah
absolutely so
let's say for a moment that we can
support the fair representation act
which would move us towards proportional
representation and then also accept that
that uh is right now not going to get
the
needs in congress without you know a lot
of things changing yeah what do you see
as the
the next set of steps for
reformers and i'm so glad that you've
gotten a lot more interest around
these measures in the last number of
months unfortunately because people are
seeing how it's all turning to [ __ ]
around us
[Laughter]
so
so what do you see as the sequence
well you know i mean i think actually
what you're doing is an important part
of the sequence which is party building
party organization yeah let's do it
let's go because i think there's there's
this this sense that you know there's a
lot of people who are
political independents or politically
homeless but you know without a sense of
of oh i belong to a party and i feel
like there's a sense of idea you need a
tribe you need a banner yes so i mean i
think i think what you're doing is
absolutely what we need to be doing is
and you know and maybe there's some
other parties at different parts of the
political spectrum but a sense that you
know there are some alternatives and you
know maybe you pick a few races
strategically to run a candidate in uh
and so if you were to try and push us
towards particular races are there
features that you're thinking like ooh
that would be ideal aside from winnable
obviously well you know i mean i think
there are
you know i mean i think the places to to
to compete would be
in districts that are you know lopsided
for one party or the other where so if
you were to run in a district in new
york city where there's not going to be
a republican challenger but there might
be some republican voters who you know
might might you know support attracted
to someone who's not the the hyper
liberal democrat who won in the primary
or
you know vice versa if there's you know
some conservative very conservative
districts where you know some somebody
like you know lauren bobert or marjorie
taylor green wins the republican primary
there's a lot of republican voters
they're never going to support a
democrat but you you run as a forward
party well well that's something
different and
so this is one of the main insights and
i've been trying to tell people this
hope you back me up honestly all
politics is tribal
at this point and a lot of folks and i
had this experience directly will just
completely shut down if you have a d
next to your name or an r next to your
name right so if you have something
neutral next your name they were like i
don't know what to make of this exactly
right you know i mean the the the label
democrat is so loaded right now for so
many people uh but you know you could
have the same person saying the exact
same things with something else next to
them it's called an independent or a
forwardist or whatever and people have a
completely different reaction right and
you know you you kind of make some
gestures just to some cultural identity
symbols that are important and suddenly
oh this is a different person amen yes
so this is what we're working on with
the forward party and i'm happy to say
that there are different folks who see
that we're chasing down the structural
changes that would enable more parties
to exist and i'm the first person to say
that i don't want three parties i do
want four or five or six parts that's
what we gotta have
[Music]
uh so it's not necessarily about the
forward party candidate winning
everything or having control over
everything though i have said to people
and i hope you agree
that if you were to get even a few seats
in congress you could have outsized
influence because of how polarized right
the the country is and thus the
legislature right if if if you had say
six
members of the forward party who were
elected in 2022 and seated in the
congress and the and the balance of
power in the house were was was
you know less than six seats
you could say we're going to vote for
whichever
speaker
you know meets
you could control the speaker that's
incredible
i you know yeah i mean or if you had one
senator you know one senator in a 50 50
senate or 49.50
depending on which way the 49.50 goes
this is achievable everyone we can get
this done maybe in 12 short months if we
put our hard hats on which i'm super
excited about so
you you've been ahead of the curve this
last several years a lot of people are
concerned about well i'll say concerned
about i mean who the heck knows where
people are leaving but um but people
project and i'm in this group project
that
uh republicans are probably gonna take
back the house in 22
uh which is next year yes uh and then
it's going to be very difficult for
democrats to get a whole heck of a lot
done for the following two years
then we'll see a trump biden sequel in
2024
and
know that there is
a lot of uncertainty as to who prevails
in that scenario um some people would
favor trump if things don't
shift appreciably between now and then
i've got a core thesis for you let's see
if you agree with this okay i'll know
let's do it so so the core thesis is
that americans have been getting
increasingly upset about what's been
happening or not happening in our
government for the last let's say 27
years for fun uh just to match it up
with
what you described and so
they they keep we keep casting about for
different solutions because the previous
team is letting us down uh philip howard
described it as the parties playing you
lose i lose you lose i lose while the
people just get more and more pissed off
bill maher said that the only message
americans understand now is throw the
bums out and it's just whoever the bums
are
and obviously anymore the time get the
brunt of that and so this thesis i'm
becoming increasingly persuaded by is
that people keep casting about for a
change from the previous thing while we
get while we get more and more insane
the whole time
um and so this dynamic would probably
lead one to favor the out of power party
in 22 and 24
because saying hey we're doing great
like you know give us the ball again for
four years is going to be less
persuasive then uh they too have failed
you
uh and let's uh you know
like burn it all down uh you know more
or less is one way to look at it um what
do you think about that general
uh description of the arc
so uh political scientists have their
own term for this it's called
thermostatic public opinion
uh
and you can think of it as you're in a
room and you know it's it's too hot so
you turn it to to a little bit colder
but but there's a bit of a lag and then
it gets too cold then you're like it's
too cold so we got to turn it back to
too hot uh but in this metaphor the the
the cold keeps getting colder and the
hut keeps getting hotter and there's no
70 degree setting which would be very
pleasant uh so
so this is called thermostatic public
pressure they're a thermostatic public
opinion and this is this is you know i
mean there's almost this clockwork
uh if you look at midterm elections
going back as far as we've had midterm
elections the president's party almost
always loses seats unless there's some
some like extraordinary circumstances
there's a few cases uh where where that
hasn't held but almost almost always
it is held and the idea is that people
want government to do more when
republicans are in charge and then
people say oh government's doing too
much so the country's moving in too
liberal direction so now this is not
most people because most people are
solidly are or solidly d but there is a
certain slice of the electorate i don't
know i mean it's been shrinking over
time uh you know we we just put it at
seven percent before who's just sort of
pissed off all the time and you know oh
you know biden made these promises and
oh now he's not doing this oh well maybe
we'll put the republicans back in and
also what happens in the midterm
elections typically is that the people
who who you know in this case democrats
you know they they were so jazzed up to
throw trump out and now okay trump's
gone so we don't you know
maybe we're not really going to turn out
whereas now republicans are so angry
that that democrats are in power that
they're going to turn out so there's
this sort of differential mobilization
that's happening also but the the effect
of it is the same that you know we go we
go
you know too hot too cold
way too hot even more way too cold and
you know eventually the whole the poor
thermostat it's gonna it's probably
gonna break if only there was some sort
of like
setting in the middle where people could
if only there was some setting in the
middle the warm we should have called
ourselves the warm party the just right
party the goldilocks party
you can see where this is going
[Music]
so
uh
so it sounds like
most political scientists yourself
included would expect conventional
wisdom to hold next fall yes uh but this
idea of thermostatic public opinion it's
so excellent
that a lot of us instinctively
have sensed that dynamic and the fact
that it's got its own name must mean
it's very real it's very legit and
buttoned up
there's
send you a lot of papers and books
proving it um so you wrote another paper
that came up recently that argued that
proportional representation
is
uh
i'm not sure if you use the word
necessity but would be a massive plus
for a stable democracy if that democracy
is multi-ethnic and uh diverse yes
and yeah this was a piece in the uh just
just out in the nyu law review
and the argument here is you know
basically what i'm trying to do is drawn
a lot of uh comparative constitutional
scholarship which is there's a lot of a
lot of scholars who look around the
world and say what what what are the
constitutional rules that make for a
healthy multi-ethnic multiracial
democracy and you know we in the u.s we
think like having a multi-racial
multi-ethnic democracy is this like some
this is like this radical departure but
actually you look around the world and
there are a lot of multi-ethnic
multi-racial democracies some are
relatively stable some are not so stable
give us an example of a good one uh you
know i i think uh
belgium is a i mean it's not i mean i
don't know it's a great one but you know
it's canada came to mind for me canada
uh new zealand actually is a pretty good
example of a stable multi-ethnic canada
too um
you know yeah uh
but the the
the insight
that a lot of folks have had is that the
thing that you want to avoid in a
diverse multi-ethnic multi-racial
society is winner take all institutions
and there's a reason you want to avoid
that is because when power can be
concentrated in just
the 51 percent and the 51 percent can
rule over the 49 percent uh that that
makes elections awfully high stakes and
it makes it really hard for groups to
share power and fundamentally it's the
same insight we were talking about with
madison before which is that if you want
to make
[Music]
democracies
democracy work you need to have fluid
coalitions you need to have different
groups working
together on some issues and not other
issues uh
yeah
but but sometimes working together right
you know
coalitions are fluid different allies
different enemies and and you don't want
to have a a situation in which one group
can gain total power i mean people say
multi-ethnic multi multi-racial
democracy can't work what about new york
city it's the most diverse place
probably in the world
and you know
no no one group has is is trying to have
dominant power over any other one group
it's not a binary it's uh how many how
many ethnicities are in new york a lot
of ethnicities for sure though we do
have one dominant political party we do
but i suppose that
that one party is uh splitting up power
in various ways yeah yeah that that is
the idea and yeah i think new york state
would work better if it were a
multi-party city too but the idea is and
this is you know an idea that that
madison got
from
voltaire which is which is about you
know religious liberty there's one
you know religion it's arbitrary if
there's two religions people go
to war and try to cut each other's heads
off over what happens after their heads
get cut off and if there's many
religions then people can live in peace
because no one side is trying to
dominate the other side and that you
know that's the fundamental insight
in order to have a stable multi-ethnic
multiracial diverse society is that
you have to have a have a political
system that allow that that requires
parties and groups and ethnicities to to
work together to share power and doesn't
create permanent enemies and
winner-take-all two-party binary systems
with you know particularly with strong
presidential power really create that
binary condition which is
really bad for people getting along
especially diverse societies
i think that's something that a lot of
americans would be very very
sensitive to given that it seems like
race is the flash point for a lot of
politics nowadays
and our media and so i found this
article of yours to be an argument to be
very fascinating which is look if you
wanted to
manage a multi-ethnic society in a
stable way you'd want more political
parties yes
you know i i i mean i i haven't made
that argument explicitly myself
um but now i might start making it
please do please do
that's it's it's free other i'm just you
know i'm just getting it from others and
repackaging it you and me both lee you
and me both
so you've now been on this particular
train for let's call it five years uh
are you optimistic optimistic or
pessimistic and uh and what what do you
look forward to and i want you to be
honest because
one of the things i say in my book is
there's something called constructive
institutionalism when we all pretend
shit's gonna work out uh because we're
kind of
you know biased towards like that
framing of the
issues or problems because we represent
institutions right so you know we're
generally can do and optimistic and be
like oh you know we we do this or that
like what you know you've been in this
space for a while
uh what are you
sensing uh lies ahead for us all well
uh
short term i'm pessimistic but long term
i'm optimistic
uh yeah i think that the next several
years are gonna be really rough uh the
next few elections are gonna be i think
incredibly stressful i think i think
there will be a level of violence and
uncertainty that that
those of us who have lived in
america for on for our entire lives have
never really experienced uh
and you know that that's
i i i don't really
that train is
is speeding and i don't really see any
way of it slowing down but you know i do
think that longer term
that we we
will build back better to borrow a
phrase uh and you know i think thanks to
the work that you
and and many others are are doing to try
to think about a a a better future a
better system of governing ourselves you
know we can we can rebuild and you know
if i look at the history of american
democracy it's a history of ups and
downs uh and there have been moments in
which things have looked pretty dark for
for american democracy and then
at the at those moments of crisis you
know that
when when it becomes clear that the
status quo is is no longer tenable and
that the uh
there's no
path forward other than to to change
then then we change i think there's
tremendous parallels between now and the
late gilded age in which inequality was
incredibly high in which the two parties
were incredibly corrupt and there was
kind of an institutional
uh breakdown in the system as well as
you know changing demographics and
immigration high levels of immigration
and you know that led to the progressive
era in which we really totally
reimagined how we do democracy in
america and you know i think we made
some mistakes in the progressive era
particularly
being overly embracing of of
nonpartisanship and and the idea that
you could somehow have institutions
without politics and i hope we don't
make those mistakes again but you know i
think the the extent to which we totally
change we can put put forth the direct
primary direct election of senators uh
the referenda uh
and and uh you know initiative direct
direct democracy and most importantly
women's suffrage uh you know which
that that was a movement which you know
for for years it seemed like nothing
would change and then it changed and you
know these movements sometimes played
well with each other and sometimes
didn't there was no one progressive
movement just a lot of overlapping
social movements but you know what i see
in the the energy particularly around
young that young people are are engaged
in who are really dissatisfied with our
political system i see a lot of new
social movements organizing i see a lot
of people getting really engaged in
politics uh and you know i i think
ultimately the this moment of chaos
will cohere into uh
into a much
better and improved version of american
democracy but but i don't think it will
be without
some moments of of real
heartache and and sleeplessness for many
of us
so it sounds like you think the future
is accept politics and create systems
that allow for politics among different
parties yes so you heard it here first
folks america is going to wind up with
four or five or six political parties
and it's going to be a very very rocky
road hopefully you can help speed us
along that road uh lee like let's try
and get there as quickly and painlessly
as possible i though i i'm generally
with you in terms of read of the the
coming number of cycles uh but hopefully
we can make them better i hope so i i
hope i'm wrong and and we get there
faster yeah we find a more direct path
me too forward maybe forward will be the
path thank you so much lee
thank you this was a delightful
conversation
[Music]
you